SETH LADD: Hi, JJ.
So this is an Office Hours.
We're trying something new.
We want to just have a more
informal opportunity for our
Dartisans communities to ask
us questions, and with the
alpha of Dart M3 landing--
was it this week?
Last week, this week?
JOHN: It was this week.
SETH LADD: This week, the new
Libraries V2 is now available
for everyone to play with.
This is a significant milestone
for the Dart
project, and it's an opportunity
for us to go and
update all of our code to the
new, awesome futures, streams,
collections, and various other
changes to the APIs.
And so here's Office Hours, an
opportunity for you guys to
just reach out to ask
us questions about
what's going on.
And then what we'd really love
do is help you guys upgrade
your packages and libraries
to Dart M3.
So this is a fantastic time
to just ask us how
to update your code.
You can use it by screen sharing
your screen or just
asking us questions, and it's
really just an opportunity for
you guys to ask us what's up.
So if anyone has any questions
please, go ahead and fire
away, and we're here
to help you out.
AUDIENCE: Seth.
SETH LADD: Adam?
AUDIENCE: OK, so I have one
question about migration.
Should we be moving towards the
streams pattern more than
just using the auto
update feature?
And a follow-up to that is just
a warning to everyone
who's upgrading with stuff that
depends on JS Interrupt
if you change the library name
for JS Interrupt, your js.map
calls will actually get
transformed to js.mappedby,
which is incorrect
[INAUDIBLE] file.
But just keep that in mind, if
you do a lot of JS Interrupt
dependency.
SHAILEN TULI: That's an awesome
bit of feedback.
That's if you use the cleanup
ability of Dart editor, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it gets a
little too aggressive.
I mean, everything else so far
has worked pretty clean except
for that one thing I noticed,
and it probably happens with
anything that's called Map
where you name a library.
But I noticed it for
the JS Interrupt.
SETH LADD: Any chance that
there's a bug for this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I filed one.
SETH LADD: OK, cool.
Thanks.
SHAILEN TULI: Good, thanks.
SETH LADD: Good.
So going back to your original
question, should we, as a Dart
community, move more
towards streams?
I think the answer is
a resounding yes.
It's already happening in the
core libraries themselves.
For instance let's see, Dart
HTML's now adopting the stream
paradigm, or the stream
libraries.
Dart I/O is--
I think there's a branch
for Dart I/O
refactoring toward streams.
And so, yeah, yeah, please,
please start using streams for
your asynchronous version
of iteration.
If you think about traditional
iterators, or that is like For
loops, that's a pull model.
You're going to synchronously
pull from the iterator.
Streams are kind of the
asynchronous push model of
these sequence of events will
happen when I'm ready, and you
will be notified of those.
So sometimes you want a
traditional iterator,
sometimes you want to have a
more push-based iteration, and
that's what streams are.
So certainly try
to use streams.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: Who here's actually
tried to update for the latest
library changes?
Who's gone through the process
with their code?
SHAILEN TULI: You have.
SETH LADD: No, that that's
a great question.
Yeah.
Who's tried to upgrade to M3?
JOHN: So I've upgraded to M3
on many of my projects, and
actually Adam helped
out with Specter,
doing some of the upgrades.
For the most part, it was a very
straightforward upgrade
experience.
I'm trying to think, the biggest
change I had was I had
used some of the future.chain
method, and the way you can
translate a future.chain to the
new API is to just replace
chain with then.
That's it.
So long as the then clause
returns a future, it will act
like a chain.
SETH LADD: Perfect.
SHAILEN TULI: And if you ever
used .value, that also is now
just .then.
.then is it.
That's the way--
everything sort of converges
to .then, and
that simplifies things.
SETH LADD: That does simplify,
but I think John brings up a
subtle point.
What you return from inside
.then sort of dictates what's
going to happen next?
JOHN: Yeah, there's a real
implicit piece of information
there, which is if you return,
say, an int or some instance
of other class, then
it operates just
like then used to.
But now, if you return a future,
then it's a chain.
SETH LADD: You can chain
it off of that.
OK, cool.
I also know that you've got to
import Dart async, dart:async
now if you want to use future.
In fact, when I run--
so hot tip, if you guys are
upgrading, use the editor's
cleanup feature.
There's going to be little
quirks like Adam was pointing
out with JS Interrupt, but
generally, it's going to save
you a lot of time.
But what it doesn't do is
it doesn't also import
dart:async for you.
So it'll switch chain to then,
but then you have to go in and
type in importdartasync,
so heads up on that.
Luckily, it's just one line.
JOHN: Another little quirk,
and I expect the editor's
automatic upgrade feature will
fix it, is it's no longer
futures.wait.
It's future.wait.
So that's a very easy fix, but
that was actually littered
throughout my code, and so
I just had to go in.
SETH LADD: Yeah, yeah.
No, that's a really point.
Futures is gone.
SHAILEN TULI: Also, timer
is no longer in--
timer is in async.
SETH LADD: That's right.
SHAILEN TULI: And that's another
thing that you may
have imports to other
things, Dart I/O.
AUDIENCE: Another bug that maybe
should be filed is when
you import dart.json, and you
go through the upgrade
process, maybe the cleanup tool
should also rename the
JSON library for you.
So it's like import dart.json
as capital JSON most people
[INAUDIBLE].
JOHN: That's a good
one actually.
SETH LADD: That's a nice
clean up to add.
JOHN: Now the JSON library has
a stringify and parse as top
level functions, whereas before,
they were static
methods in the JSON class.
SETH LADD: Now, do you
like that change?
JOHN: What I did was what Adam
suggested, where I went in and
replaced every import dart.json
to import dart.json
as JSON, all capital letters,
and then you don't have to
change your code.
SETH LADD: Cool.
AUDIENCE: I think this is
similar [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN: [INAUDIBLE]
too general to be in the
global name space.
SETH LADD: I don't know.
I like the idea that we can take
advantage of top level
functions, and you can always
just import with a prefix, and
that works OK.
But yeah, for a classic
[INAUDIBLE]
static methods, use the
top level functions.
I don't know.
JOHN: I know.
I go back and forth because it
is cleaner in a way, but I
don't know.
That was a weird change.
And I have some of my other
classes have stringify and
parse in them, so I just feel
like it's a name that's going
to be used all over the place.
So by changing the import to
be as JSON, one, I maintain
compatibility with the existing
code, and two, it's
like I've now optionally
encapsulated it into its own
quasi name space.
SETH LADD: Yeah, so you
have the choice.
But it's a good tip.
You're right.
Most the time, we're going to
want to do as JSON, uppercase,
just to make it easier
to migrate.
JOHN: Exactly.
For migration, it
becomes trivial.
Nothing has changed
with JSON if you
change your import line.
SETH LADD: Cool.
AUDIENCE: That's exactly what
I was going to say.
Going forward, probably go to
the model where we don't
rename the library, but
for all the code
that already exists--
and there's a pretty heavy
amount where every library has
some import of JSON--
just makes that migration
pattern much easier.
AUDIENCE: So there's an
important thing that I found
out when I was porting Dart
HTML5 samples, and that's that
not every thing that you need
to update will be caught by
the type system, and so it's
really, really important to
run the code.
So I don't really have unit
tests for Dart HTML5 samples
because that stuff's kind
of hard to unit test.
And so there's stuff that
breaks that had no type
warnings at all, and so it's
really important to actually
run the code.
JOHN: Yeah, JJ, I've been bitten
by something similar to
that in the past, and that's
why I manually
migrated all of my code.
So I actually went down that
road, and the auto update
feature missed a couple things,
and then it became
this weird game of what did it
catch and what didn't it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I wasn't even
using the auto update.
I was just looking for errors
and fixing them, and when they
were fixed, I was assuming
everything was working.
And it's just not the case
because there's some subtle
ways that a bunch of things come
together so that you have
to run the code.
Things have changed enough.
Yeah, I filed a couple bugs
for things that might have
been able to be caught, but
you got to run the code.
SETH LADD: Good advice.
JJ, was there something specific
that you were more
taken by surprise when you
did this migration?
Like some specific advice you
could give to everyone?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I don't know
about specific advice
besides running your code,
but there were a couple
ones that bit me.
It used to be that when you
would call a function that
would go off into webkit land,
and you wanted the JavaScript
default, you could just pass
null, and it would
automatically treat that as
the JavaScript default.
But that no longer works, and so
you have to explicitly pass
the JavaScript default if
that's what you want.
There's some really weird corner
cases with some of the
way that the Dart API doesn't
quite match up with the
JavaScript--
JOHN: Did we lose JJ?
SETH LADD: I think we
lost JJ, but good
advice on his way out.
JOHN: I get the impression
that's going to be the
direction that we're
moving in general.
We're moving away from add event
handler, remove event
handler, to streams, and that's
a big divergence from
JavaScript.
So I think you should try and
write code toward Dart and not
rely on some compatibility
with JavaScript.
SETH LADD: Yeah, I think that
was part of Adam's question,
is should we just go ahead and
embrace the stream API as the
way to fire off this
sequence of events?
I think the answer's
absolutely.
SHAILEN TULI: Streams
are the future.
SETH LADD: There's
no question.
The future's here today.
AUDIENCE: So another thing that
really bit me is that I
was calling this function that
used to return a list.
And so I was receiving it into a
local variable, and my local
variable even said list.
I wasn't using [INAUDIBLE].
I was using list, but then
that changed iterable.
But in Dart, you could downcast
without an explicit
cast, and so Dart looks at
that, and it's like, oh,
you're downcasting.
You must know that it's actually
a list and not just
an iterable.
Well, the fact of the matter
is, it wasn't a list.
It was an iterable, and so then
when I tried to index
into that list, it crashed.
And so that means that, because
the way our type
system works, it's very, very
friendly, but in that case,
you could only catch that
problem at runtime.
It won't be caught with
the static warning.
SHAILEN TULI: Sure.
Yeah, so you need to
remember to call to
list, to set, to whatever.
JOHN: Or be aware that
something's not return
iterable, as well.
Yeah, both of those things.
AUDIENCE: But if you have a
large code base, you might not
know where to look to find those
problems, and that's why
I'm reiterating again, the
only way to find those
problems, as far as I can tell,
is to run the code.
SETH LADD: Yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I got hit by
that, too, in mappedBy.
So mappedBy, I think, returns
iterable, and I couldn't
figure out what was going on.
[INAUDIBLE]
is mappedBy also returns I think
a read only view to the
list, or something like that.
So I actually had pop it
out into another--
just call two lists, and
then I actually got an
[? editable ?]
list.
And I'll just make one more plug
before I kind of step out
of here to let someone else
join and ask questions.
I realize that I've refactored
two separate
types of code bases.
The ones that used a lot of
the optional types seem to
refactor much better
than the code bases
that didn't use any.
So I think that was a big win
for the optional type system
and the Dart editor.
SETH LADD: Nice.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Great.
SHAILEN TULI: That's great.
SETH LADD: Actually, this is a
good question for the people
who have joined.
Do you use the static type
annotations to annotate your
local method or function
level variables?
Anyone?
Just join in.
It's OK.
AUDIENCE: So I can tell you
the rule that I've been
following for Dart
HTML5 samples.
I explicitly state the type if
it's not dead obvious looking
at the code.
Now, if I'm calling a function,
and that function's
not in my file, it's coming from
elsewhere, then I won't
know the type unless I look
at the code, and so I will
specify type.
But if I'm setting a variable
into some static value where I
could just reason about
the code directly,
then I just used var.
So for me, it's really like if
I could look at this code
without any other code, and I
could mentally figure out the
types, then I use var.
Otherwise, I use a real type.
And that's kind of a subtle
variation on what we normally
do, which is just always
use var locally.
SETH LADD: Well, to be specific,
the style guide says
prefer using var.
The style guide is not use
only var inside methods.
AUDIENCE: That's right, and I
think we had a long, long
discussion about the word
prefer, and so yeah, prefer.
SETH LADD: But it's totally OK
to use the type annotations if
that's what you want.
I'd love to take that poll
because I'm kind of curious.
JOHN: So coming from C++, I
cannot break the habit of
using type annotations.
The only time that I kill
out the type is when I'm
explicitly calling a constructor
because then it's
just very redundant.
Or when the line of text,
because the type name is so
large that it's like going over
the 80-character limit,
I'm like, well, let's just
shrink that down.
SETH LADD: Abstract class
factory, class factory.
SHAILEN TULI: R random
equals new random.
JOHN: Yes.
SHAILEN TULI: But you would not
do random random equals
new random.
JOHN: Yes.
SHAILEN TULI: Good.
JOHN: Because the type is
already on that line of code.
SHAILEN TULI: But your OCD
doesn't kick in when you don't
put random at the start?
JOHN: It's hard to break
the habit, but I'm
starting to get there.
SHAILEN TULI: OK.
Good.
SETH LADD: Good.
Great to hear that.
SHAILEN TULI: vars are
there for a reason.
Right?
JOHN: Yes.
SETH LADD: Hello to the new
people that have joined.
Yeah, this is an Office Hours
for you guys, so ask away.
What do you want to know?
It doesn't have to be
specifically about M3,
although that's what we're
all trained to do to
help you guys today.
But what's on your mind?
All right, I'm going to start
calling on people's names if
you guys don't--
AUDIENCE: That's not a
bad idea, actually.
SHAILEN TULI: Are
people talking,
and we're not hearing?
SETH LADD: Yeah, if someone's
talking, we can't hear you.
Just FYI.
AUDIENCE: Can you
hear me, Seth?
Hi, guys.
SETH LADD: There you go, yes.
Hi, Ali.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Just, you mentioned
in the [INAUDIBLE]
that [INAUDIBLE]
on.click.add would
be [INAUDIBLE].
Is that [INAUDIBLE]
warning in the [INAUDIBLE]
editor?
I don't see a warning
on the old format.
SHAILEN TULI: It is
a warning, yeah.
SETH LADD: That's a good
question, so you barely came
through, so I'll reiterate
for you.
The question was the
recommendation is to move to
the new stream-based APIs in
Dart:HTML, which would be
element.on, click.listen, which
replaces the old way to
do it, element.on.click.add.
But as Ali points out, and we
noticed too, is that there's
no warning on the old way to do
it. on.click.add does not
give any sorts of warnings.
I suspect that's because the
engineers are being really
nice and giving us this
grace period.
Maybe what we should do is file
a bug and ask them to add
deprecated to some of those
APIs, but the generalize
advice is move to
.onClick.listen ASAP because
the old way will be removed
as far as I understand.
AUDIENCE: So, Seth, I was
thinking I might just wait
until the warnings come out
because that'll make my life
so much easier.
What do you think about that?
SETH LADD: Well, if you've got
cycles now, probably the
advice is to move to the new
APIs as soon as you can.
A, they're going to get ripped
out anyway, the old ones, but
B, if you notice something when
you go to the new APIs,
and you provide some feedback
for us, that's
really, really valuable.
So I would say as soon as
you can, do it and let
us know how it goes.
JJ, when you moved to some of
the new APIs, you had some
really good feedback and
insights into the process.
OK, so what we can do now is
Shailen's actually prepared a
couple samples using the new
APIs, and so please do ask
some questions here in
the Office Hours.
But, Shailen, do you think we
can show just a couple of some
of these new samples?
SHAILEN TULI: Oh, sure, sure.
So not knowing fully who was
going to be showing up and who
wasn't, I sort of prepared
something that starts with
very basic stuff and moves up.
I don't know how much of the
basic stuff I should skip.
Should I just--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: I think you should
go ahead and show us some of
the basic stuff.
SHAILEN TULI: OK.
SETH LADD: And, Ollie, if you
don't mind, can you mute?
And of course, if you have a
question, go ahead and unmute.
JOHN: So why don't we start
with the basics.
And if we start to hear a lot of
people say, you know what,
this is too simple, then
we'll skip ahead.
SETH LADD: OK.
I like it.
JOHN: So speak up if this
is way too basic.
SETH LADD: And if you
can't see the fonts,
please let us know.
We try to embiggen them
a bunch, but we can
embiggen them more.
So, do this if you can't
see anything.
JOHN: Is it "embiggen"
or "bigify"?
SETH LADD: Oh, "embiggenify."
SHAILEN TULI: "Embiggenify"
is a good one.
SETH LADD: It's a
technical term.
SHAILEN TULI: All right.
So our cameras are up there,
my screen is down there.
So if I'm burrowing down like
this, it's not because I don't
want to look at you guys.
But this is how it is.
All right, so example
one, really simple.
We got Completer so I create
this level function called
getNum Create a Completer
completes it, and returns
completer.future.
It's just going to give
you the number 4.
And then--
SETH LADD: So, wait, what
are we seeing here?
What are you demonstrating
here?
SHAILEN TULI: So I am
demonstrating future's 101.
SETH LADD: Got it.
Futures 101.
SHAILEN TULI: So if you know--
SETH LADD: What is a future.
SHAILEN TULI: A future--
what is a--
you know, it's hard answer the
question without using the
word "future."
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN: It's a promise.
SETH LADD: It's a promise to
use the word "future."
SHAILEN TULI: A future is--
well, I'm trying to do this
without using "future."
SETH LADD: Don't worry,
use the "future."
SHAILEN TULI: OK.
That something will be given
to you in the future,
it's not there now.
And when it's given to you, then
you will do something.
SETH LADD: I like it.
OK.
SHAILEN TULI: Right.
So the [? when ?]
then plays nicely with
the API .then.
SETH LADD: Why are futures
important?
SHAILEN TULI: Well, sometimes
things are expensive, and you
don't want your application
to block.
We don't think like
that in Dart.
We think asynchronously.
SETH LADD: And, specifically,
we don't think that way
because Dart is a single-event
loop execution environment.
Think of it as--
[? queue ?] right, and you're
going to just pop off all
these little work items.
They may be call-backs.
They may be instructions.
Any time one of those guy's
does something really
expensive, you're blocking
everything else.
And so if you can return this
token, this future token, you
return it right now, the event
loop can keep going, and when
that value's ready to be given,
it can just be put on
the event loop, and eventually,
oh, I'm ready now.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
So it's like, I'm going to keep
doing other things, and
when you have something
to give me, then
I'll listen to you.
SETH LADD: I like it.
SHAILEN TULI: All right.
So, unless anybody has
objections, this is just--
this little page is over.
SETH LADD: Ah, no.
JOHN: Oh, whoa.
SHAILEN TULI: You have
an objection?
SETH LADD: What is
a Completer?
JOHN: Objection.
SHAILEN TULI: What
is a Completer?
SETH LADD: Why do you have
that native code there?
SHAILEN TULI: Well, so this
is how you are return
a future, and so--
JOHN: Maybe one way to think
about it is, if you look at--
there is a receiver--
there 's a thrower
and a catcher.
So the Completer
is the thrower.
The Completer is this object
that eventually will throw the
value to the catcher--
the future.
SHAILEN TULI: And it's not
aware of who's catching.
It has no notion of that.
It throws--
[INAUDIBLE]
JOHN: So the pattern you see
with the code there is you
instantiate a new
Completer class.
And then, from within that
function, you return
completer.future.
You don't return the value that
you've completed upon.
So that future then gets grabbed
by the calling code.
They assign their then
method to it.
And then whenever the Completer
calls the complete
method, that future becomes
the value itself.
And it's then that it calls.
SETH LADD: Perfect.
Perfect.
Now this is a bit contrived
example because this doesn't
show the long-running
or expensive
asynchronous operation.
Imagine [? inside ?]
getNum would be like
a database query.
SHAILEN TULI: All right, here.
So since you brought
that up, let's go
to the second example.
SETH LADD: Yes.
OK, here we go.
This drives it home.
SHAILEN TULI: So, I didn't
actually tell Seth to segue so
beautifully, but--
SETH LADD: We're linked,
like a--
SHAILEN TULI: I actually don't
think I need [? .io. ?]
But I'm not going to try
to break anything.
All right, here we go.
So it's the same getNum Now,
it takes two seconds.
JOHN: Before it completes.
SHAILEN TULI: Before
it completes.
Now, so--
SETH LADD: It takes two seconds
before it returns a
value, but we should say that
this function is going to
return instantly.
SHAILEN TULI: Perfect.
SETH LADD: The getNum is going
to return instantly.
SHAILEN TULI: Perfect, yeah.
So there's two things.
So getNum has three parts.
You create a Completer object,
that's the first part.
Completer or complete
is the second part.
OK it's wrapped in a timer here,
but that's what it is.
And then returning
completer.future.
Because most people think very
synchronously about code, it's
tempting to think, OK, the first
thing happens, then the
second thing happens, then
the third thing happens.
The whole point of async here
is, the first thing happens.
Yeah, you got a Completer
object right away.
The last thing happens,
you return it.
And then the second thing
happens when it happens.
JOHN: Correct.
SETH LADD: Yeah, at
some point later.
SHAILEN TULI: At some point.
It could happen really right
away if you're just returning
the number 4, but if you're
waiting two seconds, and then
returning the number 4, then it
happens two seconds later.
SETH LADD: And this is what I
like about Completer here.
You can take that instance
Completer and, thanks to
lexical scoping, access it from
deep within a bunch of
call-backs, or you pass
it to some other guy.
So whoever's got a handle
on that Completer
can complete it.
And then magically, whoever's
listening on that future will
get that value somewhere else.
JOHN: Exactly.
SETH LADD: I like that.
SHAILEN TULI: So let
me run this.
So notice that the returning
showed up.
I don't know if you
can see it.
SETH LADD: No.
JOHN: It's kind of small,
because you can't embiggenify.
SHAILEN TULI: Embiggenify?
SETH LADD: Hm, that's a bug.
It's unembiggefiable.
JOHN: So for those of you who
aren't in the room with us,
the first line says
"returning..." And you can see
that print statement clearly
in the source code.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, and I've
highlighted it down here.
So you have to trust us that
that's really what it says.
And then, the 4 shows up a
couple of seconds later.
JOHN: Yes.
SHAILEN TULI: Right?
So here in our main--
JOHN: Actually, if we could be
more explicit, what happens
after two seconds is that the
then statement executes.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Correct.
SHAILEN TULI: Then has nothing
to do until it gets something.
JOHN: Yes.
SHAILEN TULI: Sorry,
I interrupted you.
SETH LADD: No, you're right.
SHAILEN TULI: So again,
getNum .then is--
JOHN: What you're doing is your
cuing in the future when
the Completer has completed,
call this function, in which
case there's a closure, which
just prints the value.
SHAILEN TULI: OK.
So--
JOHN: So this is the pattern
you're going to see over and
over and over again
in code that uses
Completers and futures.
You instantiate a Completer
[? inside ?] of that function.
You return completer.future.
[? dot ?]
And then, the calling function
is typically going to be
chained immediately
with a .then.
SETH LADD: Yes.
And futures are really great
for one-time events.
I want to get a value, and
there's only going to be one
value that's going to come
out of this thing.
JOHN: I want to do an HTTP
request, and when it is
finished, then I want to print
the JSON or parts of the JSON,
and get something out of it.
SETH LADD: Now, contrast
that a little
bit with, say, streams.
Right, now the stream API is
designed to allow you to spit
out a sequence or series
of these events.
Future's really a
one-time deal.
I'm only waiting for one kind
of event to happen.
When I'm done, that's it.
JOHN: So my go-to examples for
future versus stream is a
future is an HTTP request.
It's like this single thing
that you kick off.
And it's going to take a while,
and it will complete.
Whereas a stream
is an on-click.
The user could be clicking
over and over and
over again, and it's--
you're not requesting
the click to occur.
You're just being told
that it happened.
SETH LADD: And many, many
clicks can happen.
JOHN: Yes.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
Exactly.
Perfect.
All right, by the way--
oh, go ahead, JJ.
AUDIENCE: We're reading--
my favorite is reading
lines from a file.
You could have a stream where
it's giving you a bunch of
lines coming from a file.
Then you could modify that
stream to create another
stream, which is all the
lines coming from
the file, UTF-8 decoded.
And then you could modify it,
create another stream coming
from the original stream,
in which case
you break it on tabs.
And so, I think of it as UNIX
pipes, in a certain sense.
SETH LADD: That's right.
JOHN: There's a lot of
analog there between
streams in UNIX pipes.
SETH LADD: This sounds
like a good
segue to get into streams.
Do you have some stream
stuff for us?
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah--
SETH LADD: Or are we
jumping ahead?
SHAILEN TULI: Well, depends
on what we want to do.
There's no jumping ahead.
SETH LADD: Do you guys have any
questions about the basic
kind of concepts about
Completers and futures?
And if you're shy-- oh,
we've got a chat.
OK.
Perfect.
Sorry, guys.
You should definitely
use chat, as well.
That's fine.
We'll start actually monitoring
this now.
"I'm a Java programmer, so it's
in my blood to use static
type, the Triborough"--
OK, cool.
Thanks, Frank.
JOHN: I'm a C++ programmer,
Frank, and
I'm in the same vein.
It's very much just in my
blood to put the types
everywhere.
I like it.
It's very verbose.
SHAILEN TULI: To me, either you
use types, or you don't.
So--
SETH LADD: I don't know, I think
there's definitely a
middle ground.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SHAILEN TULI: Well, OK, clearly
in Dart, there's a
middle ground.
SETH LADD: Yeah, yeah,
not in Dart.
Are there other languages?
SHAILEN TULI: Well, no, what
I mean is, Dart, might--
the way my head is wired, I'm
saying either I put vars
everywhere, or I put random
equals new random.
And so it takes a little
adjusting to say, OK, I don't
need to do this verbose
thing everywhere.
SETH LADD: Oh, you mean
traditionally that's how your
brain was wired.
JOHN: Interestingly enough, C++
is actually moving towards
the Dart way.
In C++ 11, they introduced the
auto keyword, which, just like
Dart's var keyword, it just
automatically deduces the type
based on the right-hand side.
SETH LADD: So we should probably
be really specific
about that.
So in Dart, var is
not like auto.
In Dart, var is a stand-in
for Dynamic.
Now the Editor--
if there's a flag in Editor,
you can be like
a little bit smarter.
But it's going well above
and beyond what the
language back is saying.
As far as Dynamic,
there is no auto.
I write code with the checkbox
for the Editor that says, do
some extra inferencing for me.
Definitely, I think it's
super helpful.
JOHN: So in that sense, they're
not the same, but the
programmers are moving towards
that way where it's like, I
don't need to write
out the type.
If the compiler of the tool can
deduce the type for me,
why write it out?
SETH LADD: Anyway, guys, we're
watching the chat now, so go
ahead and use that, or just wave
your hands and speak up.
That's why we're here for you.
But you've got some more on
futures then, I think.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah, actually,
I played around with error
handling in futures yesterday.
SETH LADD: Oh, good topic.
SHAILEN TULI: I got deep into
it because I kept getting
bitten and wasn't sure
what was going wrong.
So, if you're trying to use
.then in the Editor--
let's just try it here, OK?
Tell me if you guys
can see this.
Notice it tells you that,
oh, it takes an onError.
SETH LADD: OK, so these are
two different call-backs.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
So basically, it's a common
pattern, right?
When things go well,
do something.
When things go badly,
do something else.
Right?
Beware of onError.
And if we have time, I'm going
to try to convince you to
never use it, and use better
things that Dart gives you.
So I'll go through
that quickly.
So here's--
close this.
That doesn't matter.
All right.
Here we go.
OK, so here's a simple
error handling.
So you've got a function named
foo, which should be returning
a number, but it doesn't.
It throws.
And you have another function
called getNum, which is the
standard one for all
our examples.
And this one returns
a future, right?
But this time, it calls foo
internally, and then it uses
completeError.
SETH LADD: So here, you're
writing getNum with the
expectation that something
bad may happen.
So you're smart, you write
the try, the catch, OK.
And that's where Completer
comes in again.
SHAILEN TULI: Right.
So here we go.
So if things go well, we put
the value of whatever foo
gives us into val.
And we return that
completer.complete--
the same stuff we
had seen before.
We're good to go.
If things don't go well,
we need to do this.
This is how you basically
throw arrays
in the async context.
If you just write "throw,"
I don't think--
it kind of, sort of
just falls apart.
SETH LADD: Hopefully you have
an example of that, because
that's where I think that
onError might come in.
But you're right, this is--
you expect something
may happen.
Let's do the right thing,
completeError.
SHAILEN TULI: Right, so whatever
is returning the
future should handle errors that
it gets from somewhere
else or raises internally, and
omit those errors using a
completeError.
OK?
Then, this is what your
handling of all
of that looks like.
So here we go.
We call getNum.
We put a then.
And this part--
let's see if I can
highlight this--
is the success, right?
We get the value for whatever,
and we print it.
But we're not going to get it
the way this is written,
because foo, as we said,
throws, right?
So then, you should just
call .catchError.
Not onError and I'll explain
in a minute why.
SETH LADD: Yeah, so, let's
actually point that out,
because you're not--
this catchError handler is not
part of the then call, right?
You're actually chaining
something to the end.
And so then--
and then chain on a catchError
to the future itself.
SHAILEN TULI: That's right.
So, you're saying do this, and
then if there's failure, we
use catchError to catch that.
In this case, let's just run it,
It says it's not going to
give you an end.
It catches that error.
AUDIENCE: So there's
an important thing.
Some of my code was calling
basically getNum
and getting a future.
And then I would do it in two
statements, I would do a
future.then, and then I would
do a future.catchError.
And that is not the
right thing.
You need to do it in
a single chain.
SETH LADD: Excellent,
excellent point, JJ.
Why don't you reiterate that,
because that's a tricky one.
AUDIENCE: So if you call
getNum and it returns a
future, and some of my code was
saying future .then, and
then later, future.catchError.
But because the way futures
work, that ends up setting up
two different chains of future
handlers, and that is not the
right thing.
So if you're going to
use catchError, you
want to chain it.
SETH LADD: Excellent.
So, JJ, we did--
thank you for bringing
this up.
We did what you should not do.
I think this is what you're
saying, right, don't do this?
AUDIENCE: Don't do that.
SETH LADD: Right.
SHAILEN TULI: Because
essentially,
you have two things.
Now here, this is
going to just--
oh, we can run it.
OK.
This was not supposed to work.
SETH LADD: Oh wait, let's
see here. getNum--
ah, this is it.
SHAILEN TULI: Oh,
it needs to be--
SETH LADD: You do this.
And then you say--
this is I think what
you're saying, JJ.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's right.
SETH LADD: Because
this will return.
Try that.
Now, is that still doing it?
Maybe it's two different
thens.
AUDIENCE: No, we're not reproing
the correct case, but
this is definitely the broken
way of doing things.
And there was an email to the
mailing list about this, but
this actually bit me
in my own code.
In any case, remember
to do the chaining.
SETH LADD: It sounds like what
we should do is, let's take an
action item.
We'll write up a blog post.
We'll repro the exact
situation.
And we'll show the don't do
this, and we'll show the do
this version.
So thank you very much
for bringing this up.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah, I'm going
to write up all this stuff,
and then I can add
that stuff there.
Can I make this slightly
smaller?
I actually can't navigate.
SETH LADD: No, I'm
really-- this is
going on YouTube later.
The bigger, the better.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, OK.
So--
AUDIENCE: One more
thing, Shailen.
So it used to be that
you, as far as I can
tell, you had to call--
what is it?
A handle error--
I can't see your code.
It's a little bit up.
SHAILEN TULI: Where I defined
the function?
Here?
AUDIENCE: A little bit higher.
SHAILEN TULI: That's
just foo throwing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
So it used to be that you'd have
to call completeError, or
whatever, handle error,
whatever.
Not handle error, but--
SHAILEN TULI: completeError.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, completeError
before.
And that you couldn't just
raise an exception.
But [? Florine ?]
was saying that, actually, if
you raise an exception, it'll
be caught by the system, and
automatically translated into
completeError.
And he told me that,
and I tried it.
It didn't work, but I think I
was using a slightly older
version of the SDK.
So this might actually be like
brand new functionality where
I think it might be the case
that, if you happen to raise
an error, it will get caught
and translated into
completeError.
That makes life a little
bit easier.
SHAILEN TULI: I wonder actually,
though, if he was
talking about something slightly
different, which is
in your then, if you raise an
error, that's where onError
will kill you, and catchError
will beautifully help you out.
But I'll try your thing, also.
SETH LADD: So it sounds like
we-- let's write up a blog
post on different ways these
futures can throw errors, and
the right and wrong
ways to chain.
This is great.
We definitely more here.
SHAILEN TULI: So onError.
Now, let's just go back to the
way the Editor, at least for
now, is telling you
to do this, right?
The same getNum you call--
oh, OK--
you call foo, and it throws.
getNum again, call foo, check
to see if there's an error,
and sends out a completeError.
Now, if you've re-throw
in your then,
this will fall apart.
SETH LADD: OK, so here
we have then.
We know that foo is going
to throw an exception.
SHAILEN TULI: Right,
so this will catch
foo's exception nicely.
onError will catch it.
But because you're then also
did some mischief--
SETH LADD: Oh, so you're
not rethrowing.
You're just throwing a
new exception there.
Sorry, that confused me.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah, throw
something new.
SETH LADD: OK, that
makes more sense.
SHAILEN TULI: Oops.
Sorry, guys, I'm not
used to this font.
OK.
Throw something new.
That something new now will
not be caught by onError.
But it will be caught by--
SETH LADD: Why don't you
run the code now.
What happens?
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so--
all right, this is
not [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN: I think you need to change
foo to return 4, and
then throw from inside
there, right?
Because the then clause will
never execute the way it's--
SHAILEN TULI: Oh yeah,
I'm sorry.
That's why I had it as that.
OK, I changed it without
thinking.
Here we go.
Thank you, John.
There you go.
We called it, foo returned 4.
So, there was no problem here.
SETH LADD: You have
no problem there.
SHAILEN TULI: Completer.complete
could
happen normally.
In here, you got into
the then normally.
And you printed the
value, which I can
attest actually happens.
The number 4 was returned.
That's a value.
That's what you get.
And then we threw something new,
and at that point, all
hell broke loose.
There was no way
to handle that.
SETH LADD: Got it.
SHAILEN TULI: You do
this catchError.
So again, you return
a 4 from foo.
You handle that.
All the code is the same.
And, OK, I [INAUDIBLE]
"rethrowing." I'll just
say "throw something."
SETH LADD: That's fine.
SHAILEN TULI: Right?
And now, you run it.
And it says, ah, you threw
something new.
I can handle that.
So that, for me, a real blessing
of using catchError.
It's one of those things,
it's just--
I don't know if there's
a bug--
I don't know what scenarios
there are where you would want
to use onError and
not catchError.
SETH LADD: Cool.
But we will find out.
And we're going to document
that for everyone.
I like it.
SHAILEN TULI: One last point.
And this is being made by people
on the mailing list.
This is a huge point.
So again, we go back--
so this is about when you
do error handling.
If you wait too long, it's
going to bite you.
So again, foo throws.
getNum is exactly the same.
It does what it was doing
in previous examples.
Now, we call getNum.
And we put all of this stuff,
the then, all the onError,
inside a timer.
SETH LADD: OK.
SHAILEN TULI: So anyone want
to guess what happens here?
JOHN: I know, so
I won't guess.
SETH LADD: But getNum is going
to throw an exception.
SHAILEN TULI: Right.
At this point--
SETH LADD: And num
is a future?
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
SETH LADD: OK.
SHAILEN TULI: So, I
should have called
it something better.
It's not a number.
It's a future number
or something.
So at this point, the error's
emitted, and there's no
one to handle it.
Because your onError is getting
attached after three seconds.
And in this case, onError
is not to blame.
The same exact same thing
happens if you use catchError.
If you put it in a timer, OK?
SETH LADD: Go back to
the other example.
What happens?
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so--
you want me to run it?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
SHAILEN TULI: Of course.
There.
Uncaught.
It says, uncaught error,
unhandled exception, blah,
blah, blah.
And it gives you all
the details, right?
If you do this with catchError,
catchError is good
for other things.
So this works because I called
getNum inside the new timer.
But if I had done this, that
should not work now.
AUDIENCE: So I think the key
point you're raising is that
there's a race condition here,
and if you're going to call
something that returns a future,
you need to call .then
as soon as you get
that future back.
You can't do it later because,
if you do it later, you're
going to hit this race
condition, and things won't be
set up correctly.
SETH LADD: And that's because,
if you miss a loop in the
event loop, right?
JOHN: Yes.
That's exactly it.
SHAILEN TULI: I can move
the streams now.
There's one [INAUDIBLE]
I just mentioned it.
It is very simple.
Not [INAUDIBLE].
I'm sorry, whenComplete, I don't
actually know if this is
brand new, but I don't remember
seeing it before.
Maybe it was called
something else.
SETH LADD: I don't know,
let's go down the code.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so again, so
here I've modify foo slightly
to randomly either return
the number 4, or
throw a string, OK?
So, again, getNum
has not changed.
It's the same.
It does some--
try and catch, and then
it returns, OK.
In meme--
SETH LADD: Oh, yeah,
this is new.
Yeah, go ahead.
SHAILEN TULI: This
is new, right?
So this is the equivalent--
you know when you write in
synchronous code, when you
write finally where you try
something, you catch an error.
But whether you catch, or
there's no abnormal
termination, you want
something to happen.
So you put in that finally.
Well, this is the async
version of finally.
So here, we say, all right,
we'll call getNum.
If everything goes well,
we'll print the value.
That's here.
If there's an error, we'll
print the error.
But regardless, we
will do this.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Run it.
SHAILEN TULI: So run it.
JOHN: And you'll note there
that, in the source code,
these are all chained.
They're all chained
from each other.
SHAILEN TULI: They're
chained, yeah.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
So in this case,
in my example--
I know this is a little
small to read--
you have the number 4 being
returned, because that's what
foo gave you.
And it says, "when complete, run
regardless of success or
failure." OK, do it again.
SETH LADD: I was going
file a bug that
you're missing a comma.
SHAILEN TULI: Missing
a comma, yeah.
SETH LADD: But you
fixed the bug.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, well that's
the same-- oh, there you go.
So now it threw.
Not going to give you an int,
but this ran again.
So this is a very contrived
example, but a more--
SETH LADD: No, whenComplete
is awesome.
SHAILEN TULI: whenComplete
is great.
But for instance, I think there
is code in [? ..io, ?]
where you sometimes have to
create a temporary file or a
temporary directory, and then
pass that to a function.
That function could return
something, or it could throw.
But in any case, you want to get
rid of that temporary file
or temporary directory
when you're done.
So that's what whenComplete
is about.
Anyways, this is finally in
an asynchronous context.
SETH LADD: I love it.
We might get kicked out of this
room, though, so do you
have a quick way to show
us some streams?
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so
I have three demos.
I had a mappedBy thing, but
that's Adam and a bunch of
other people--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: Let's try to
at least-- what's
the concept of streams?
Show me a simple example.
SHAILEN TULI: Streams--
OK.
AUDIENCE: You could probably
drop down your font.
I think people in the next
room from me can
actually see it.
SETH LADD: The trouble, though,
is when this goes back
up on YouTube, we lose a lot.
So we're going to have
to keep it big.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SETH LADD: But you can
put a return there.
That'll work.
SHAILEN TULI: OK,
so when you--
this is a very simple example
of a single subscription.
AUDIENCE: Hey, sorry, guys.
Can I just drop in?
SETH LADD: Hello?
AUDIENCE: Hello, Hello, I just
have a quick interruption.
SETH LADD: No problem,
please ask away.
AUDIENCE: It's just that, I was
up in the YouTube stream--
SETH LADD: I'm sorry?
JOHN: Say that again.
AUDIENCE: The sound
is a bit slow.
But if you go into the YouTube
stream, you can only see you
three guys talk.
That's very exciting, but
most people would
like to see the code.
SETH LADD: Yeah, no kidding.
Weird.
I don't know how
to change that.
Thank you for the heads up.
SHAILEN TULI: You know,
I have this on gitHub.
Should I just put
out the link?
JOHN: Yeah, we'll
put it in the--
SETH LADD: We'll put it
in the show notes.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: So, Seth, if you're
doing the Hangout On Air from
your laptop, why don't you
click on the window
that has the code?
SETH LADD: I have.
In fact, that's how I've
been running it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SETH LADD: Yeah, guys, Sorry, I
thought that's what we did.
SHAILEN TULI: So, is everyone
having this problem, or--?
SETH LADD: We're talking
about just the YouTube.
JOHN: Just the YouTube.
SETH LADD: Can you-- oh.
Can the YouTube stream
literally not
see anything else?
Oh, cameraman.
Oh, Google effects--
Sorry, OK, well, we're going
to have to work on that.
What if I share my screen
of the Hangout?
We can go deeper.
Well, you know what.
OK, sorry.
My apologies for that.
We're going to do some tests
afterwards, and we're going to
figure out how to fix
that for next time.
We're going to get kicked out of
here really soon, so maybe
we could just be really verbose
with our description
of what's happening here for
the last couple minutes.
SHAILEN TULI: Not only-- oh you
mean verbose, because they
don't have that.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so there's
two kinds of streams--
single subscription, and--
SETH LADD: Sorry,
let's back up.
What is a stream?
AUDIENCE: Actually, I can
see code now on YouTube.
SETH LADD: OK, cool.
SHAILEN TULI: I'm sorry, I don't
know your name, who said
they couldn't.
SETH LADD: That's Frank.
SHAILEN TULI: Frank.
Frank, can you see it?
SETH LADD: Well.
If, JJ, you can see it, I'll
make sure this is--
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I haven't
just looked at it.
SETH LADD: OK, no worries.
Streams.
What are streams?
SHAILEN TULI: What
are streams?
This is like the equivalent
to what are futures.
JOHN: So I think we kind
of touched on this
a little bit earlier.
A future is a single event.
A stream is a sequence of events
that are asynchronous
that will arrive at some
point in the future.
In the same way that you have
the future as a then clause,
the stream you then
subscribe to it.
SHAILEN TULI: You
have a listener.
SETH LADD: You have an onData.
Which is really like
"onThing-you-care-about." So,
many examples of streams.
You used button clicks, right?
You can have a series
of button clicks.
Bytes-- so JJ used to I/O.
Great example, right?
Bytes in a file, like give me
when I've read a certain
number of bites over and
over and over until
the stream is closed.
Bytes over a socket.
Web socket events is another
good use for streams.
JOHN: Yeah, that would
be another stream.
SETH LADD: I'm sure there's
plenty others.
But that's a stream.
And OK, cool.
SHAILEN TULI: So here's a very
simple, streams 101 example of
a single subscription.
So the language is a little--
so there's emitters
and listeners.
We emit events.
Then there's also streams
and subscribers.
So the language is a little
mixed up in our API, but it's
the same stuff we're
talking about.
Something is streaming, and
something is listening or
subscribing, OK?
So here's a stream.
We create a stream from an
interval, a small list--
1, 2, 3.
And we stream out the square
of 1, 2 and 3.
So the first thing that comes
out of there is 1, because 1
squared is 1.
Then.
4.
And then 9.
This is a contrived example.
And this is a single
subscription, which means
there's only one subscriber
to this stream.
SETH LADD: Or this stream
expects only one subscriber.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
So, nothing happens unless
there is a listener--
I'm sorry, I'm confusing--
unless there is a subscriber.
SETH LADD: Right.
SHAILEN TULI: Right.
Then, so we put all that
in a mapStream object,
mapStream.listen.
And now, we have a listener
subscriber, and it waits.
So i is going to be 1.
It'll print that.
Then the next thing from
the stream is 4.
It'll print that.
And the next thing from
the stream is 9.
It'll print that,
and it's done.
The stream is exhausted.
If you do this, we have a
second listener, it will
complain mightily.
SETH LADD: Well, but before you
do that, comment that out
and run it so everyone
can see.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so the true is
for when I was asking if it
wanted a single subscription.
Is it a single subscription?
Yes, it is.
And then print out each event,
each thing that you got from
the stream--
1, 4, and 9.
That's what you get.
If you try to do this again,
it won't work.
Bad state, stream already
has a subscriber.
You can't trick it.
But you don't need
to trick it.
There is a nice way
to do this.
So you can have the
stream [INAUDIBLE]
by as many subscribers
as you want.
So let's look at this example.
It's a simple example, again,
but the listening thing is
more complicated this time.
OK, so, again, we just call--
oh my god, how did I do this?
OK.
SETH LADD: No, because you've
defined stream--
SHAILEN TULI: Oh, I've
defined it up there.
That's why.
OK.
I'm sorry.
This is what happens when
you have 48-sized font.
All right, so we have a stream
object that I've
defined way up here.
So all my functions
can have it.
And now I say, give me a new
stream from this interval--
1, 2, 3-- just like
we did last time.
And here's the important
line--
asMultiSubscriberStream.
And then you just say, OK, I'm
going to just return the
square of those three
numbers each time.
So, I have defined foo,
bar, and bot.
Hold on about foo right now.
Bar and bot--
bat--
simply listen for everything
coming through the stream, and
then print out a simple message,
saying, in this
function, this is--
SETH LADD: So each one
of those functions
sets up its own list--
subscriber slash listener.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
So there are two listeners for
now-- one inside bar, and one
inside bat.
And we are, in fact, calling
those two right here.
OK, so if we run this,
it'll say-- and I'm
sorry if this is small--
"in bar, i equals 1," "in
bat, i equals 1." "bar
equals 4." 4, 9, 9.
SETH LADD: So we see subscribers
dealing with a
series of just fine.
SHAILEN TULI: So this is
actually a simple case where
this happens.
If you look at the API,
there's ways to
do it that it goes--
so right now goes 1,
1, 4, 4, 9, 9.
If you want, you can go
1, 4, 9, 1, 4, 9.
But in the interest of time,
you can explore that.
Exercise for the reader.
Isn't that what you say when
you don't want to go into
something, that it's an exercise
for the reader.
But, there is something else
that's kind of cool about all
this stuff, which is I've
defined a function foo which
actually kind of just sort of
mixes things up a little bit.
So let's look at foo.
Like bar and bot, foo said,
I'm going to listen to the
stream, and it does the
usual printing.
In foo, i equals i.
But then it has a little bit--
and John helped me with this
yesterday--
if i is 1, it says,
call bar, also.
If i is 4, call bat.
SETH LADD: In other words, set
up another stream listener
either at the beginning
or the end.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
So arbitrarily, we have picked
these points to--
SETH LADD: But what's really
happening here is you're
setting up a new stream
subscriber in the middle of
the stream's ability
to send events.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
SETH LADD: OK.
Awesome.
SHAILEN TULI: So
let's run this.
So, we'll go through
this line by line--
foo is saying we know the stream
is going to be sending
1, 4, and 9, right?
So foo says, so that you
predictably will see in
foo i equals 1.
Great.
If i is 1, you call bar.
But you don't see that now.
You'll see that the
next around.
SETH LADD: Because you
already missed the
emitting of the event.
SHAILEN TULI: Right.
One came and went, and bar
missed the boat on that one.
SETH LADD: Sure.
SHAILEN TULI: So next time, when
4 comes out, it says, i
equals 4 in foo.
Sorry, in reverse--
in foo i equals 4.
In bar, i equals 4.
So bar has joined in, gotten
in to the action a little
late, but he's they're now.
SETH LADD: Sure.
SHAILEN TULI: And so in our
code, we say, if i is equal to
4, get that into the
action, too.
So now, the third time when
9 comes around, well, foo
consumes it first.
bar consumes it next.
And then bat consumes it.
That's the only thing
that bat consumes.
There's a lot you can
do beyond. this.
This is just a simple
get-you-started example.
SETH LADD: What this illustrates
to me, though, is
that streams are really--
it's a stream.
And so, if you introduce the
listener in the middle of a
stream, of course he's
not to get any of
the previous events.
But he comes in right
there for every
other subsequent events.
JOHN: I mean, we can extend
the list even longer.
We could add 16, then keep
going, and then all three of
them would start getting
everything past 4.
SETH LADD: Bingo.
SHAILEN TULI: So, before--
I'm sort of rushing because I'm
fearing a knock on this
door that throws us out.
So I've built a small,
little app.
So when you create a new--
let me just get rid
of all of these.
When you create a new web
application using the Dart
Editor, it gives you that
familiar click me-- oh, why
don't I just do it?
I am sorry.
I'm sorry, folks.
It's my computer that's
complaining
mightily about something.
JOHN: I think it's the
screen trying to.
SETH LADD: Hey guys, make sure
if you have any questions, you
can type them in the
chat window here.
Or, of course, just by
[? waving ?] your hand.
Was that a hand wave
for a question?
Maybe not.
So anyway.
Make sure.
We are here to answer your
questions, so let us know.
SHAILEN TULI: All right,
I screwed up.
Never mind.
SETH LADD: For the sake of time,
let's just look at the
async demo here.
The one you got prepared.
SHAILEN TULI: So
you will get--
OK, I'll explain.
SETH LADD: Don't worry
about the old way.
Tell us the new way.
SHAILEN TULI: So, let's
just run it, and
you'll see it's familiar.
Well, sort of.
It said click me, right?
And you click it, and
it goes backwards.
So now I do a few other
things to it.
Let's get rid of this.
So this syntax you will have--
SETH LADD: Why don't
you minimize this.
SHAILEN TULI: Yes.
So the syntax you
would have is--
SETH LADD: So I'm going to
move it up one level.
So what we're showing here,
we're showing the use of
streams and the new Dart
HTML library together.
So we're showing you some simple
bit of browser code
that is using the
new streamified
versions of Dart HTML.
SHAILEN TULI: So the original
code, if you were to create a
new app, would create
this element.
SETH LADD: Show us what's
going on here.
SHAILEN TULI: And it would
say, .on .click .add.
Now we already taught, that's
yesterday's news.
What we do this now is
el.onClick.listen.
So onClick is going to
give you a stream.
And when you listen
to it, you get a--
John, is it stream subscriber?
JOHN: Stream subscriber.
SHAILEN TULI: A stream
subscriber of some stream
subscription object.
SETH LADD: Oh, that's return.
Yeah, sorry.
SHAILEN TULI: So onClick returns
a stream, and listen
returns a listener, which, if
you want to look at the API,
is a stream subscription
object.
And in that, I call
the original
reverse text function.
And then, it's a contrived demo
of showing how you can
pause the stream, and
resume the stream.
SETH LADD: So that looks a lot
like Ruby or Python code?
SHAILEN TULI: No.
SETH LADD: Yes
SHAILEN TULI: Why?
SETH LADD: It's not
camel-cased.
SHAILEN TULI: Oh.
OK.
SETH LADD: I'll file a bug.
SHAILEN TULI: I can't put commas
in the right places, I
can't camel-case.
What am I good for?
JOHN: GitHub has an
issue tracker, and
so we'll make sure--
SETH LADD: Yeah, don't worry.
I'll send you a pool request.
SHAILEN TULI: Well, so,
what is pause--
SETH LADD: You should
probably actually--
no joke, it'd be really cool
to show off the renaming
capability.
SHAILEN TULI: OK.
SETH LADD: You want to
do that really quick?
AUDIENCE: Actually, Frank
has a question.
He's wondering what the return
objects for all of those
different things are.
So maybe you could talk about
the return object of onClick
and return to object
of onClick.listen.
SETH LADD: OK, great question.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so why don't
I, instead of spending time on
pedantic stuff--
AUDIENCE: Yes, I see the irony
in me telling you not to spend
time on pedantic stuff.
SETH LADD: If you let this
go, what's next?
SHAILEN TULI: OK, so
the stream object--
so var stream--
SETH LADD: Is onClick
a getter?
Yeah, okay.
JOHN: [INAUDIBLE] fields.
Returns a stream.
AUDIENCE: So maybe you could
just right click onClick and
right click on listen in
order to see the types.
SETH LADD: Maybe just hover,
I think maybe-- yeah.
Is that what you mean?
Put the cursor there.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN: It's a stream.
SHAILEN TULI: It's a stream,
guys, I promise you.
Stream.
OK?
SETH LADD: No need to yell.
SHAILEN TULI: I'm sorry
I'm yelling.
JOHN: Take one exclamation
point off of there.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
I'll file a bug.
SHAILEN TULI: OK, guys, in
subscript, which should've
been named something
slightly more
pronounceable, is stream--
SETH LADD: Subscription.
SHAILEN TULI: Stream
subscription.
SETH LADD: You got
that right there.
SHAILEN TULI: I have that.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: I have a
quick question.
Is there anything that this new
approach to HTML handlers
can do that the old approach
couldn't do?
JOHN: Yeah.
I'll demonstrate that.
SHAILEN TULI: I mean, the
old approach-- in plain
JavaScript, if you want to
add or remove [INAUDIBLE]
handlers, it's a complete
pain, but
you can do it, right?
So there's all sorts of
stuff that you can do
now, but much easier--
what happened?
SETH LADD: Nothing.
Ignore me.
SHAILEN TULI: All right, let
me-- can I just sort of talk
through this code, and I think
hopefully that will answer
your question.
OK, so, here we go.
We get this element, which
we found up here, right?
We found an element with
a particular ID.
And we said onClick [INAUDIBLE]
a stream, listen
to that stream, and call reverse
text, so "click me"
becomes the reverse.
And then you call, pause,
and resume a horribly
not-camel-cased OK?
So pause and resume--
JOHN: Horrible.
SHAILEN TULI: Takes a
subscription object, right?
And it pauses--
it calls a little helper.
Maybe I should not have
made my code so dry.
Basically, what it's saying
is, subscr.pause.
OK?
Here, it causes it, calls
pause, and it basically
toggles the class.
SETH LADD: OK, but let's
go up a level.
So streams can--
sorry, subscriptions can
be paused or resumed.
JOHN: Correct
SHAILEN TULI: That's right.
So when you--
SETH LADD: So what does that
mean from a subscription--
without walking me through
the code first.
Talk about the concepts.
So, the reason why you
care about the stream
subscription handle--
subscr--
is because you want to control
when you're getting events on
that stream subscription,
right?
And you do that by pausing it?
Or resuming it?
SHAILEN TULI: OK.
Or canceling it.
SETH LADD: Or cancelling it.
SHAILEN TULI: Right, John?
JOHN: Yeah, if you're done
with a subscription--
SHAILEN TULI: If you don't want
to listen anymore, you
cancel and you're out of this.
JOHN: The old way
would be, like,
on.click.remove event handler.
And now that you have
the subscription,
you just call cancel.
SETH LADD: And canceling
is just canceling your
subscription to this
sequence of events.
You are not canceling
the stream itself.
JOHN: Yes, the stream can be
done, but that's an entirely
different [INAUDIBLE].
SETH LADD: Exactly, right.
Yeah.
SHAILEN TULI: You would need a
stream controller for that.
That's another topic.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
Yeah, so this pausing--
just so we're utterly clear--
this pausing, resuming, and
canceling is only about your
receiving of the events.
It could be other subscriptions
to the stream,
and you call pause, whatever,
they're not paused.
JOHN: While a subscription is
paused, any events that are
emitted by the stream
are buffered.
So you don't lose any events
when you're paused.
The other people will get the
events if they have a
subscription that's
not paused.
So you're not blocking the
other subscribers.
It's a choice for the
subscription.
SETH LADD: It's like
a TiVo pause.
When you press play again, you
resume where you picked up,
not where the time
actually is.
I like it.
SHAILEN TULI: All right.
So all I'm doing in
this example.
If we run it--
I've been monkeying with it,
so I hope it still runs.
OK, here, and I'm actually going
to give you a little bit
of console help.
I don't know if I can
make that big.
Anyway, the point is, in the
default Dart example that you
get, you click this and
it becomes backward.
You click that and get
"click me" again.
You can keep going
back and forth.
[? Pleasant ?], I decided to
make it a little annoying,
which is you can click,
but then for
two seconds, it pauses.
And after two seconds,
it resumes.
So let me demonstrate that,
and then we can look
at the code, OK?
So I click, and I can
click all I like,
nothing's going to happen.
Now, it's clickable again.
I don't know, can you
make this big?
JOHN: Oh, let's not
worry about that--
SHAILEN TULI: Well, I
just wanted to know
[? where pause count ?].
JOHN: But that's an internal.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
JOHN: That's like an
implementation detail.
SETH LADD: Well, what we're
seeing here is you are pausing
your subscription.
So even though there are clicks
happening, you're
subscriptions, your listeners
aren't receiving those things
because it's been paused.
Which is cool.
SHAILEN TULI: The subscriber
here is paused.
I logged that.
And then I put a little
time out--
SETH LADD: That should
be timer.
SHAILEN TULI: Will that work?
JOHN: You can put
timer up there.
SHAILEN TULI: You can
put timer, yeah.
And then, I resume it.
And pause and resume are just
very thin wrappers for--
JOHN: [INAUDIBLE] if I
was incorrect about
the way pause works.
SETH LADD: It may
not queue it up.
SHAILEN TULI: It may
So the important thing to take
away from this is it keeps a
reference count of
this, right?
If you pause twice, and you want
to resume, you need to
resume twice, too.
SETH LADD: Oh, that's
the point.
OK.
SHAILEN TULI: If you don't, if
you pause twice and resume
once, it throws up its
hands and says--
SETH LADD: So, let's take
a note and figure out--
JOHN: We're still pause then?
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Let's figure
out why that is.
There may be some
reason there.
Pause is not-- you're not
toggling some state, it sounds
like, because you have to toggle
it the same amount--
pausing and unpausing.
SHAILEN TULI: Yeah,
so there is this--
so here.
Can you make this big?
Here we go.
So I click, and it says,
pause count is 1.
But then it just reverted
back, and now
pause count is 0.
So that's basically
what's happening.
It's a counter internally that's
just keeping track of
how many pauses, how
many resumes.
SETH LADD: Oh good, we're
getting a question from Roman.
Oh, maybe not.
But this is a good time to say
we're going to wrap it up in
just a few minutes.
If you guys have questions,
now is a
good time to ask them.
Jump in the chat.
Wave your hands,
ask with voice.
Any last questions about some
of these new features in the
Dart libraries?
No?
OK.
Cool.
Well, hopefully you guys are
updating all your code to M3.
We've seen a lot of traffic on
Pub as people are uploading
the new packages, which
is awesome.
We're also seeing people take
their new packages and put
them on to drone.io, which is
a continuous integration
service that has full support
for native Dart apps.
So if you want to ensure that
your code keeps working, then
you should totally use drone.
It's very cool.
Ah, yes.
Beer o'clock.
I like it.
And so, lots of cool things to
keep your apps updated, and
running all the time with our
continuous integration
partners, drone.io.
Very cool.
SHAILEN TULI: I'll write
up all this stuff.
I'll put it on gitHub.
And I'll send out emails to the
mailing list and to Dartisans.
SETH LADD: OK.
SHAILEN TULI: G+.
SETH LADD: Cool.
Well, let us know if this
format works you guys.
It's office hours.
And how we can make
it better for you.
We want to make sure you have a
good conduit into the team.
And if this live Q&A
thing works you
guys, then that's cool.
We'll keep doing it.
So I want to thank John and
Shailen and JJ and, definitely
thank all of our watchers
and guests.
This is really, really
appreciated.
You can find us on the
Dart mailing list--
misc@dartlang.org.
You can find us on Stack
Overflow, tag Dart.
You can find us on
Google+, +Dart.
And our Dartisans community
on Google+.
So, lots of good ways
to get a hold of us.
Yeah.
I think that's it for today.
Everyone have a great weekend.
And we appreciate it.
And we'll see you online.
Bye.